you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the ft's white
hall editor sebastian payne and the
belfast telegraph columnist alison
morris they'll be with us from now until
just before midnight so let's see what's
on some of those front pages now the
times has an interview with the prime
minister who says he finds police forces
neglecting the issue of violence against
women infuriating
speaking to the telegraph the home
secretary priti patel has made similar
comments
women are facing an epidemic of indecent
exposure reports the guardian which says
police recorded more than 10 000 cases
last year but took fewer than 600 cases
to court
the eye hears that army personnel will
begin driving fuel tankers from monday
in an effort to ease the petrol shortage
that's also the big story for the mail
the mirror describes boris johnson as
having been caught short by the supply
crisis
according to the financial times the
drug maker merck is to seek regulatory
approval in the u.s to distribute the
first pill that actively treats covid19
and which murk claims halves the risk of
death from the virus
the sun meanwhile says that the england
football team has been thrown into
disarray as several players are refusing
kovid jabs despite qatar's entry ban on
all unvaccinated people
falling holiday prices and the scrapping
of covid tests to travel have led to a
surge in bookings that's the lead for
the express
while the star has word of a shortage of
a different kind apparently we've run
out of clowns
who's going to be upset by that we're
joined tonight by sebastian payne and
alison
morris uh good to see you both um let's
start with the
times and that um
interview with the prime minister who's
uh furious over the police inaction on
on violence against women anderson to
you first
i do i think it's obvious that the the
fallout from um
the the sir everyone case is going to
end up with this kind of comment from
people like the prime minister from
pretty patel um in terms of how the
police are handling these these crimes
against women and we know that there has
been an epidemic and an upsurge in
violence against women since the start
of lockdown and i do believe that from
the prime minister this is genuine if
you remember and recall back his wife um
carrie simmons was very um instrumental
in the the john warboy's case and trying
to have his parole revoked um and i know
that she's been instrumental in
campaigning for tougher sentences for
sex offenders so i think this is
something you don't have to have someone
who has been um you know has been
impacted by a crime like this to feel
strongly about it but i do think that
the prime minister generally does
feel very strongly about this and you
would hope that it shouldn't have taken
a tragedy like this to try and show the
entire criminal justice system from
start to finish that there needs to be
more to underprotect women but it does
need to be from the ground up you know
when women report a crime to the police
they have to be sure whether it's the
metropolitan police whether it's the
police service of northern ireland that
when they get that call out that they
will get the same consistent service
across the board and that the criminal
justice system and the courts and the
public prosecution service will take
these crimes seriously and that's
something that i think you know as we've
been speaking about the fallout from
this awful horrendous case that is
something going forward that i really
would hope that there will be some
serious reform and change to how these
cases are handled yes and sebastian in
the interview the prime minister says
that the public are right to feel that
the police are failing women and girls
who are subjected to violence and sexual
abuse that is extremely
damning
it is and i think the fact you've got
the prime minister intervening on a case
like this shows the extent of the
problem that the met is now facing in
another interview boris johnson has
urged the public to still trust the
police and it's extraordinary the prime
minister has to come out and say that
now since you'd think that would be an
absolute given um but in that times
interview that you mentioned on the
front page there in the run-up to the
conservative party conference starting
this weekend boris johnson has kind of
said that there does need to be a
serious look at the mets policies he
needs to look at institutional reform
but crucially he still backs crested the
commission of the metropolitan police
there there's been many people across
the political spectrum today call on her
to resign from the former labour deputy
leader harriet harman to various mps
conservative labour as well as other
figures in public life but boris johnson
says that you know he worked with dame
crester when he was london mayor and he
has confidence in her but i think there
is going to be some kind of big sweeping
institutional reform at the met because
if you look at their policies if you
look at the fact that wayne cousins went
through various vetting checks um and
this wasn't detected and of course many
people are now asking questions about
were there signs missed here and we now
know the independent office for police
investigations is now looking at five
other officers who are in a whatsapp
group with wayne cousins and so
this clearly does seem to be an
institutional thing but i think you know
all you just have to think about is it
needs to move fast and the met needs to
move quickly to try and restore faith in
itself because you know many women that
i know of my age who live in london feel
completely petrified at the moment
they're worried they're very fearful
they don't feel as if the response and
the police following this horrific
sentencing and trial has really matched
up to the moment alison what what do you
think and how do you feel when you hear
the prime minister saying trust the
police
well there she is here i think that what
the met would like us to think is that
this was just one rotten apple and that
his service in the police had nothing to
do with what happened but it was
instrumental in the har he he got sir
into the car he used his police
credentials to lure her into the car he
used his handcuffs to restrain her these
are all you know important parts of this
this crime and so the met does have to
to take responsibility for the person
who was a member of their force so there
were red flags in relation to you know
and i i think that there have been of it
in the past you know 24 hours has not
been great the sort of advice that
they've given out to the women should
they be concerned if we're approached by
a loan officer stop trying to put
responsibility under the victims of
these crimes stop trying to put them on
to the women and they know what
sebastian said about his friends female
friends feeling frightened because of
this we were always frightened you know
as women and as a mother of two two
daughters in their 20s you know we've
always you know had these issues with
you know when you're out running you
know i wouldn't put headphones in if i
was out walking on my own um in case
someone come up behind me you know
carrying your car keys and your fingers
in case someone tries to approach you
we've all pretended to be speaking on
the phone the imaginary phone calls
because there's been men walking behind
us to try and put them off and because
of that fear and that it has always
existed and that's something that i
think that you know this sort of very
toxic masculinity that i seem to exist
within not just the met police and i i
bring this you know further right i
think you know police scotland the
police service of northern ireland they
all have to take a look at themselves
and say does this culture exist is there
a culture where if someone is shown red
flags or they're using horrendously
sexual or misogynist language about
women while they're on duty
is there a culture of reporting that
person or is this an old boy's club
where we all cover for each other where
none of these things are reported
whether swept under the carpet or if you
are the person who sort of raises an
alarm are you then punished for being a
whistleblower in this case we need to
look at all of this you know in a wider
context and the fact is you know women
are not more fearful of their safety
because of this case we were more we
were fearful for our safety before this
and from you know almost from birth it's
almost in grand india to take safety
measures when you're out when you're out
alone or when you're going somewhere
where you're meeting friends i mean have
you ever went to one of your friend's
house with and left well they haven't
said phone me when you get home to let
me know you're safe do men do that when
they leave each other's house i'm not
sure they do
that's an interesting point do they
sebastian
um i think some do but i think allison's
completely right that it's a it's a
totally different paradigm between men
and women when they're looking at their
safety on the streets so it's not really
comparable at all um and i just think
when you look at the response from
summon the police i agree with her as
well that it really has been lacking
that we heard from one of the police and
crime commissioners in north yorkshire i
think it was today who came out and
basically said that you know um that
women should be more careful they should
not submit to arrest and really trying
to place the burden of blame on them and
he's now wholly apologized for that but
you have to ask yourself someone who's
in that position of course police and
crime commissioners are elected
positions they do stand for office but
are they fit for that position if that's
the views they actually hold that you
can apologize for those comments but it
doesn't exactly show a huge amount of
faith within the system there and i
think the fact you've got the prime
minister and i think you've also heard
words from sakia stamina the labour
leader about this really shows the scale
of the issue here there does need to be
some serious institutional reform from
the top and bottom of policing to look
at
how this happened and where these
guidelines are and fundamentally what
can be done across the whole country to
try and regain that faith it's easy for
the likes of the prime minister to say
well do trust the police but you know
that trust has to be won it has to be
built up over many years would do feel
safe on their streets and i think it's
the damage that's been done by the wayne
cousins incident and the things that
we've heard from court this week are
completely horrific the worst possible
things you could ever hear about someone
who is serving in the police and that's
the fundamental point of this is that
this guy was a serving police officer at
the time he abused the law he abused his
position to the most unspeakable
horrific acts and i think really
everybody across our forces has to focus
on that's what's happened yes we've had
the the home secretary she's quoted in
the telegraph and saying this is a very
clear message to police to raise the bar
treat everybody in the right way um i
wonder um allison if you comment on um
the
on krista dick we we've been covering a
a yougov poll and 38 of the public think
that she should go do you think it is
that the time to be talking about that
or is that really a red herring her
staying in her position or not
this is the problem if something like
this happens you can take out the person
at the top because they should be
responsible for it and say they should
resign but who is she to be replaced
with and will that person be any better
or will that person um deal with the
issues that exist there's a problem
within the police which needs dealt with
and it needs seriously dealt with within
the met you can see that there's an
institutional issue that needs dealt
with who is going to be the person to do
that i don't particularly i think that
it matters if you remove the current
commissioner you put somebody else in
the place he's just going to be more of
the same well then it's not going to
make any difference but is there someone
there who's willing to step up and make
actual reform i actually know that
barbara gray who was the deputy chief
constable of the police service of
northern ireland is currently working
for the metropolitan police i was sorry
to see her leave northern ireland she i
thought she should have been the new
chief constable here i'd like to hear
from her because she was very
instrumental when she was in northern
ireland and trying to change the psn in
terms of domestic abuse and sexual
violence against women
so i would like to hear what barbara
gray has to say and would she maybe be
willing to come out and speak about what
actually needs to be done within the
metropolitan police
sebastian the guardian they're talking
about an epidemic in the way that crimes
against women um are um treated for one
women are facing an epidemic of indecent
exposure with police recording more than
10 000 cases last year but taking fewer
than 600 suspects to court so so really
how seriously these cases are being
dealt with is another issue
indeed just to pick up on those comments
on quest to dick that alison was saying
there you know in these circumstances
the immediate reaction people to say x
must resign because they're the
leadership person they get paid the big
wages to carry the can and carry the
responsibility here and i think you know
pretty patel the homestead he does
having an easy relationship with crested
dick that is
certainly no um no secret within
whitehall and but the question here
really is it speaks to guys so it's
about institutional reform and one thing
that boris johnson has pointed out is
the number of female police officers has
been increasing quite rapidly in recent
years now is obviously a good thing that
can certainly play into that cultural
shift and
making sure that women have feel safer
and have more confidence within the
police there but there is i think a very
real prospect as the guardian reports
that this does open the wave on a whole
load of stuff and policing across the uk
that these incidents aren't being taken
seriously enough and it feels like
someone's going to have to get a grip on
this quite quickly because you know the
sarah eva arcade i think horrified
everybody across the whole country and
further field as well when it when it
when the details broke about that and
british policing has existed for
hundreds of years it's something that is
based on consent the consent of the
people to believe in their police office
to do that and i think if you see more
stories like on the front of the
guardian saying that um these incidents
are not being fully followed up then
that consent does fall away and that
leads to a much bigger problem which is
a society we don't want to get to okay
sebastian and alison thank you very much
for the moment coming up help appears to
be on the way to solve the fuel shortage
i'll tell you more about that in just a
moment
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me sebastian payne
and alison morris there they are right
on cue
let's have a look at the mirror and
their headline caught short um basically
discussing the fact that um they're very
many sectors where there are a shortage
of workers um and this is something that
the prime minister according to sakir
stama um
really knew about
way back for quite a long time but did
nothing about it uh does that sound like
a correct summary to you alison
yeah i think that every sector is short
of stuff i mean i don't mean to rub it
in and make you make you all feel
jealous we don't have any fuel shortages
i know we know we know
we have the northern ireland protocol
which has mitigated a lot of these these
disasters but we do we do have a staff
shortage and that's obviously to do with
the fact that um the the
the rules for people from europe working
changed after after brexit and a lot of
people went home um and they just
haven't returned and that has really hit
the hospitality sector very badly and we
know that's going to have food
production very badly as well especially
as we come into the christmas season you
know we're hearing from a lot of the
supermarkets that they're not going to
be able to produce a lot of the lanes
that they usually would have at that
time of the year so something does need
to be done and i mean you know anyone
could have predicted this we were told
all of this obviously nobody bothered to
put that on the side of a bus but the
the fact was rely very heavily on
workers from other places in a lot of
sectors be it in food production or be
it without the hdv drivers which we're
saying now um and the fact that nobody
bothered dominican against that or come
up with some alternative to that um i
think she was a complete another lack of
of any kind of of government
organization and i think as we head into
the conservative party conference this
week it's not a great time to begin
india any kind of party conference is it
considering the sort of disaster that
the place is facing at the minute um and
we would like you know i think that the
fact is that there is going to have to
be alternatives and we're going to have
to look at trying to entice workers from
other places to come back and and work
here how that's done or what what
changes have to be to be made to the
rules and regulations i don't know but i
mean it's something that should have
been looked at a long time ago we're
sort of now trying to mitigate in the
face of a disaster i know that a lot of
places in northern ireland especially
the hospitality sector we have
restaurants that are only on a sort of
thursday friday and saturday they just
don't have the staff to be able to open
up the start of the week and that's
unsustainable as you you come into the
christmas period
but in terms of getting the fuel to the
pumps sebastian there is a solution
albeit uh temporary solution but the
prime minister is bringing in the army
from monday
well i just like to come back on
alison's comments because i disagree
with an awful lot of what she's just
said there that obviously there's no
doubt there is a brexit element to this
that um that a lot of people we know the
eastern european works have gone home
after that but it's simply not all about
that particular instance if you look at
all european countries they're
struggling with supply chains there's
been empty shelves in brussels in paris
in germany this is about the world we've
not seen the queues at the petrol pumps
though have we yeah i'm thinking
particularly in france we haven't seen
that elsewhere
we haven't but the
physical i was trying to get to is that
this is about a much more fundamental
fact of the world economy having shut
down following coronavirus and that it
has exposed systemic weaknesses within
various countries and one of the big
weaknesses we've had in this country is
an over-reliance on just-in-time supply
chains that in about 10 years ago the
tories sewed off some of the last
containers we had for keeping co2 gas
here which was widely cited as one of
the reasons for that and i think you've
got to look at the specific reasons
behind this before just supersizing it's
all brexit because
some of it is some of it isn't we'll
never quite disentangle it in the same
way you'll never quite disentangle while
the economic hit of brexit to the uk
economy was beat because coronavirus was
so much bigger now to your point about
the army boss johnson yes has finally
brought the army in they've been
undergoing training for the past 72
hours to drive these hgvs they'll be on
the seats for monday but i think the
most striking comments in the mail is
that this disruption could go on till
christmas and it'll be as you can see
how forgiving voters are to this that i
think that obviously if you think back
to the fuel protest in 2000 when you had
a similar situation on full courts uh it
they did absolutely nothing to tony
blair's government that i think in many
respects people aren't necessarily
blaming politicians their blame you
we have run out of time gonna have to
thank you but you'll be back and you can
speak as much as you like
in the 11 sebastian and alison thank you
so much